le temps est extrêmement chaud et
l'humidité accablante
comme dans les latitudes tropicales mais
dans l'ouest canadien la situation est
anormale
on se lève le matin et il fait déjà
chaud en fait plus chaud qu'il devrait
faire à ce temps ci au mois de juin
au milieu de la journée cette masse
d'air chaud est maintenu en place par un
blocage atmosphérique
on s'imagine vraiment comme un don des
choses certaines régions en plus comme
on pu lire dans la région ou du québec
reed honda froide et fois au courant de
l'hiver donc c'est vraiment mandat qui
assistait région
conséquence indirecte de cette vague de
chaleur certaines rivières menacent de
sortir de leur lit en raison de la fonte
accélérée des glaciers et des neige
résiduelles en montagne mais possibilité
de dommages collatéraux se multiplient
on s'exprime rajhi pour les cultures les
fruits dans certaines vallées sud de la
province mais ils risquent de forer bon
et serbie dans les prochains et la
qualité de l'air se détériore en maître
aura couvert avec me encore une fois une
alerte
ça fait déjà quelques jours pour des
niveaux toxiques de l'ozone justement à
bas niveau jeux d'eau lieux climatisés
tous les moyens sont bons pour se
rafraîchir nous sommes ici en train de
manger de la glace pour un petit
déjeuner pour commencer
rien à voir toutefois avec la chaleur
que connaissent le québec et l'est du
pays
on aime ce passionnant accord mais quand
qu'on a besoin de socialiser puisqu'elle
les enfants besoin de voir d'autres
mondes par les jeux d'eau ça reste la
meilleure option le pendant ce temps il
ya un risque de gel la nuit prochaine à
terre-neuve
un autre signe de l'immensité du
territoire canadien et de ses contrastes
c'est julie aimant radio canada montréal